I often wake up at two or three o'clock in the morning,
it takes me almost two hours to get back to sleep.
I was looking at a sleep age for aid
from black forest products that contained
right of a D, magnesium,
oxygen-gronded, deodine,
appajitted, and black pepper extract.
I wonder if that's safe for me to try.
It may, but so,
so, the,
you're gonna look at what could be the problem.
So if a person can't fall asleep,
then that's typically a,
an issue with melatonin,
an issue with clovey their brain down.
Many times, if you're looking at your screen,
whether it be your phone or a computer
or a television at night,
that's basically,
basically programming your brain
because all screens are vibrate at 60 hertz.
So you're basically up,
programming to a, you know,
your brain to a super high beta wave,
and you have to get down to a theta wave
about 11 hertz in order for your brain
to calm down enough to fall asleep.
So it's not advisable that you use,
do a lot of screen time before,
you go to bed if you're having trouble falling asleep.
You could also have an issue with melatonin release,
and you're not releasing melatonin,
it could be a melatonin problem.
There could be other issues too if you can't fall asleep.
But if your thing is, no, I fall asleep just fine.
I just wake up at two or three in the morning
and I just can't get back to sleep.
Then that's usually, not always,
but usually a cortisol issue.
So cortisol is released
by your adrenal glands throughout the night
in order for you to stay sleeping.
So understand, you know, during the daytime,
you are up, walking around, moving,
you're eating food, and that is helping you.
When you eat food, you're breaking it down to glucose,
and, you know, you use the glucose in your muscles
to create energy, but your brain uses glucose as well.
The primary fuel source for your brain is glucose.
That, in fact, it's said by functional neurologists
that your brain needs fuel.
So the fuel is glucose and oxygen to keep your brain alive.
You just need it.
You need glucose and oxygen to keep your brain alive.
So if you're not breathing well,
so you could have a sleep apnea issue
where you're not getting proper oxygenation into help with the brain.
That could be an issue.
And then the other thing is you're not getting
a glucose in the brain to keep the brain alive.
So then you can't fall asleep, and you get up,
and you walk around, and when you get up and walk around,
then you will help break down glucose through a process called,
you'll actually create glucose through a process called gluconeogenesis.
And that's how you'll have glucose to the brain,
and then your brain can start functioning, and you could go to sleep.
Because literally when a person gets up in the middle of the night
and they can't go back to sleep,
many times it's their brain saying,
uh-uh, I need fuel.
You need to give me some fuel.
Now the thing is, in the middle of the night, you're fasting.
So two o'clock in the morning, you're waking up.
You didn't eat since nine o'clock at night,
so you're already on a five hour fast.
And where is that glucose coming from for the brain?
It has to come from stores of glucose
that is in your liver in the form of glycogen.
So glucose is stored in this lung chain of glucose
called glycogen that's stored in your liver.
And in order for that to break down,
it breaks down through cortisol release.
So cortisol is released by adrenal glands,
and then it breaks down glycogen in your liver.
And that's how you have fuel all night long for your brain.
So if you look at a cortisol reading a daily adrenal,
what's called it, has been known as an adrenal stress test.
It's measuring cortisol four times during the day.
And in the morning, you'll see this spike of cortisol.
Well, the spike cortisol of the morning
is coming from a spike that happens at the middle of the night.
You're not getting up to test your cortisol in the middle of the night,
but you can test it in the morning.
It's coming down from the highest level of cortisol in the middle of the night.
The purpose of high level of cortisol in the middle of the night.
Why? By under stress in the middle of the night,
everybody thinks cortisol is just a stress hormone.
Well, it's not a stress hormone.
It's released at times of stress.
Why?
But it's released at times of stress
because at times of stress, you need a whole lot of glucose
in order to run away from the polar bear.
But you need glucose.
So cortisol's purpose is to break down glycogen stores in the liver
so that you can have glycogen.
So you can have glucose to either run away from the polar bear
if that stressful event happens at three o'clock during the daytime.
But it also happens at night time every night
in order for your brain to stay alive
because you're not eating at night.
So you're not eating at night?
You're not walking around at night.
So you're not getting glucose from food
and you're not getting glucose from gluconeogenesis.
So you need glucose from glycogen stores in your liver.
Now, there's probably way too much information.
Hey, I just want to know what I should take
at two o'clock in the morning.
Well, a couple of things.
You need to support if you're waking up at two o'clock
in the morning, I said all that to say that
you might have low adrenals.
That's why you would have low cortisol.
So supporting the adrenal glands.
Now, oschvoganda in this product actually is an adaptogen
that would help support the adrenal glands.
None of this other stuff would help support the adrenal glands
but oschvoganda would.
I bet you this magnesium is micrograms of magnesium
because 1,100 milligrams of magnesium is going to give you diarrhea.
So I bet you that's micrograms.
But oschvoganda would support the adrenals.
So in that sense, I think this might be a good product.
But better than that, there's some other adaptogens
on the market that have other adaptogens
other than just oschvoganda, like rodeola and jinsa,
and things like that.
I would say you might get better relief or better results
from going out of the adaptogen.
If you said I really have a trouble falling asleep,
then I would say go on something like insomnetal
which has a bunch of things to help call your brain
to help you fall asleep.
Theonite is one of those things that helps call your brain
to help you fall asleep and save with apogen.
Magnesium, depending on the form of it,
if it's magnesium, theonite, then it would help call your brain.
But I don't know what form of magnesium it is.
Black pepper just helps you absorb things in the gut.
And I'm not a real big fan of black pepper
because black pepper helps you absorb anything
that's in the gut.
So if you have ate something with toxins in it
or chemicals in it, you're going to absorb it better
in the gut, so not a big fan of black pepper.
So I'm not, it wouldn't be a big fan of this product.
I would say take a product that's an adaptogen
to help support cortisol levels.
That's how I would do it.
I mentioned if we did an adrenal stress test on you,
your adrenals are just a little fatigued.
So then what would you do to help build them up?
You could take an adrenal supplement
that has adrenal tissue in it
like a bionics research, adrenal supplement.
Or I think better would be to take an adaptogen.
So we have adaptogen R3.
That's a product from Premiere Research Lab.
Gosh, we probably have.
We have our own adaptive clear.
We have probably six or seven adaptogens in the store.
I would start with the Premiere Research Lab
adaptogen R3.
That's what I would do.
It's called adaptogen R-3.
Take maybe two or three of those throughout the day
because you want to try to build your adrenals up
throughout the day.
And see if that give it a week or two
before you're going to notice any difference.
That's, I think, what I would do.
Next question.
So back to that question.
The whole thing to be spilling out way too many words
is that whenever you have a problem,
like, you know, I wake up at two o'clock in the morning
or I can't get to sleep at night or I have headache,
you always want to try to figure out why.
We don't want to go, oh, here's this supplement
for waking up at two o'clock in the morning.
Or here's this, like you're just,
like we're using even natural things as medicine.
We want to figure out why and treat them why
and not just throw things at the wall.
So that's why I'm offering my suggestions.